je vous le dit j'aimerais qu'on
accueille tout de suite lille you et sa
mère céline parce que jude law ont fait
une surprise incroyable idiot et sa mère
série qui sont allés
désamour merci d'être là ça va au lido
c'était pas trop manqué non tu t'en fous
de moi ça va moins je suis rida mois moi
ça va merci d'être là gilliot il est fan
de jul il est fan de jul il est
paraplégique depuis sa petite enfance 8
ensuite un vaccin georgie fès a
rencontré hier je suis je l'aimais
vraiment je les adore il est
exceptionnel
il adore djukic équipe a tout de suite
et vous avez créé une association lilio
l'ange illibériens et c'est et ce afin
de venir en aide à votre fils et
améliorer son confort de vie et lilio
hier il est venu boire
il pense avoir rendez-vous chez le
médecin et en fait c'était pas du tout
ça et c'est son anniversaire qui arrive
bientôt c'est lui janvier on voulait lui
faire une belle surprise
regardez
bonjour docteur bonjour tard vous êtes
venu à clio oui il est là vous allez au
lit des eaux il m'a reconnu ou pas je
suis pas docteur je pas docteur mais n'y
a pas d'offrir aujourd'hui
bon j'ai une surprise pour toi ça te
dirait d'aller avec la famille au
concert de jools mécontents chez rien sk
communique sur loire ont fait une
surprise pour toi d'autres rappellent la
vie
tu sais que si rien n'est tabou qu'il
allait avoir une autre surprise pour toi
une belle surprise
celle ci est
pour garder un pied en mettre le feu au
quartier
pavages me remercier de ce que tu as
fait pour les lions
c'est beaucoup de choses qu'on attendait
pour lui et je pense qu'il va s'en
souvenir l'entourent
je voulais vraiment remercier jul et
toutes les équipes qui ont été
formidables ajouté un mec que j'aime
énormément qui est formidable et ainsi
faire c'est quoi ta tac effet le concert
on m'appelle matichon sur le béton filet
quand quelqu'un qui sont béton
alcoolisées encombrant il pas qu'au sens
dans mon chéri tu reviens de boire quand
bientôt quand tu veux j'invite tous les
jours tu n'en ont pas moi je te fais un
gros bisou
la série
lr s'y ajoutent les familles